.
HERE WE GO.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
HAPPY MONDAY, EVERYBODY.
OH, BOY.
SO, WITH ANOTHER DUMP OF TWITTER
FILES, WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED?
IN BETWEEN BEATING BARACK IN
ARM WRESTLING, MICHELLE OBAMA
ASKED TO BAN FROM FROM THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM, YES, HER
LIST OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDES
CENSORING A PRESIDENT AND
RUINING SCHOOL LUNCHES.
>> OTHER DEMOCRAT BUSYBODIES TO
THE SAME THING INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF TWITTER.
THE TAKE-HOME: THEY LIKE SOIL
AND GREEN.
IT'S NOT ABOUT POLICY.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE.
AND LIKE HYGIENE, THEY MAKE IT
UP AS THEY GO ALONG.
YOU SHOULD HAVE SEEN THE
ORIGINAL JOKE.
LIBERALS GENERALLY HIRE LIBERALS
WHO SHARE THE SAME FEARS IN THE
SAME BEHAVIORS.
IT'S TRUE IN MEDIA AND KNOW IT'S
TRUE IN TWITTER.
DO YOU WANT TO PROTECT YOUR
LEFT-WING ASSUMPTIONS?
OVERSTAFFED COMPANIES WITH
PEOPLE WHO HOLD THE SAME
BELIEFS.
YOU DO THIS FOR OVER A FEW
YEARS, YOU END UP WITH A COMPANY
THAT HAS 40 DIVERSITY
CONSULTANTS FOR EVERY TWO
WORKERS.
NO TALENT WHATSOEVER.
THAT'S WHY TWITTER, ONCE A SITE
WHERE ANYONE COULD TALK, WAS NOW
DOMINATED BY PEOPLE TELLING YOU
WHAT NOT TO SAY.
THE UPSIDE, IF YOU WANT TO BE
HIRED BY BIG TECH OR LEGACY
MEDIA, SHOW UP AT THE JOB
INTERVIEW WEARING A RAINBOW
T-SHIRT AND A MUSTACHE,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE A WOMAN.
IF YOU'RE A MAN, DEMAND MORE
TIME OFF HER PREGNANCY LEAVE.
BOOM, YOU'RE THE NEXT HOST ON
THE VIEW.
IN SHORT TIME, TWITTER BECAME
THE NEW TURF FOR PEOPLE TO THE
LEFT OF CHE GUEVARA'S GHOST.
LAWS WERE OPEN TO INTERPRETATION
SO THEY TWISTED THEM IN LIKE A
NASCAR RACE THAT TURNS ONLY WENT
IN ONE DIRECTION BUT UNLIKE
NASCAR, WHITE MEN WEREN'T A
FAVORITE TO WIN.
BECAUSE ONCE YOU HAVE
IDEOLOGICAL CONTROL, YOU CAN
HIRE, FIRE, SILENCE, BLACKLIST,
BAN AT WILL, HIRE WHOEVER AGREES
WITH YOU NOT JUST AT TWITTER BUT
BASICALLY EVERYWHERE.
OUR RATINGS WENT DOWN FOR
SHOWING THOSE PICTURES.
SO IT'S NO WONDER THAT OUR WORDS
COULD BE VIEWED AS INCITING
VIOLENCE FOR ITS VIEWED BY
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY HATE OUR
GUTS.
NO POLICY THAT SAYS BAN
RIGHT-WINGERS.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED IT.
THE MOBSTERS FIRST RULE WAS NOT
TO WRITE ANYTHING DOWN.
SO KEEP THE BIAS WHERE IT
BELONGS, IN YOUR HEAD.
ALONG WITH PLANS TO MAKE
PLUMBERS PAY OFF YOUR DEGREE
ENGENDER GRIEVANCE STUDIES.
ALL YOU NEED TO DO IS JUST HIRE
MORE WHAT COLLEGE GRADS.
LOOK AT MSNBC.
IT WASN'T ALWAYS [BLEEP]
CRAZY.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT, TUCKER
WORKED THERE.
I KNOW.
HE DISCOVERED RACHEL.
BUT THEN IT CHANGED.
POLICIES DIDN'T COME UP WITH THE
PEOPLE DID.
WHAT ABOUT DISNEY OR AMERICAN
GIRL, MY FAVORITE COMPANY.
SUDDENLY THOSE COMPANIES THAT
APPEAL TO ALL AMERICANS BECAME
BEHOLDEN TO A VERY FEW WHO DON'T
EVEN LIKE THEIR PRODUCT AND THEY
LOOK AT THEIR CUSTOMERS WITH THE
SAME CONTEMPT I HAVE FOR
NONALCOHOLIC BEER.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY HIRED DRONES FROM
THE LEFT-WING DRONE FACTORY,
COLLEGE.
THESE CAMPUSES TURN OUT MARXISTS
THE WAY GM TURNS OUT CARS ONTO
VD CONVEYOR BELT.
ALL THEIR FEARS ARE THE SAME AS
THEY MOCK YOURS.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT GENDER
ACTIVISTS DEMONSTRATING TOYS TO
YOUR KIDS?
YOU'RE THE REAL THREAT.
ALL GIRL WITH ENOUGH HOOKS
THROUGH HER NOSE TO HANG A
SHOWER CURTAIN.
I FIND THAT APPEALING.
ARE YOU WORRIED SOCIAL JUSTICE
REFORMS HAVE A FUNDED LAW AND
ORDER.
THEN YOU MUST BE A
WHITE SUPREMACIST, INCLUDING
YOU, LARRY ELDER.
ARE YOU WORRIED WHEN ACTIVISTS
WANT TO BAN FOSSIL FUELS?
YOU CLEARLY DON'T CARE THAT WE
ARE ALL GOING TO DIE AND YOU'RE
KILLING THE PLANET.
EXCEPT FOR JOHN KERRY.
WHATEVER ANIMAL BIT HIM IN THE
90s GAVE HIM ETERNAL LIFE.
BUT THIS IS WHY AOC GETS
ELECTED, MAXINE WATERS, THE
SQUAD.
THEY DON'T GO AWAY.
IT'S WHY JOHN FETTERMAN WON EVEN
THOUGH HE WASN'T FIT TO HOLD A
GLASS OF WATER A LITTLE IN
PUBLIC OFFICE.
IT'S WHY FOR TWO YEARS NO ONE IN
POWER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT CRIME
FOCUSED INSTEAD ON GENERATOR
SIX.
FORGET ARSON AND MURDER, GAIA
AND FURRY HAT MADE DEMOCRATS
FEEL BAD.
SOMEONE STEALING NANCY PELOSI'S
LAPTOP GOT MORE COVERAGE THAN
THE CRIMES ON HUNTER BIDEN'S BUT
THANK THE LORD THERE WEREN'T
ANY.
THERE WEREN'T ANY NUDES.
TASTEFUL.
STOP IT.
BUT IT'S ALL BECAUSE THERE ARE A
NARROW GROUP OF PEOPLE SHARING
THE SAME VIEWS TO CONTROL OF ALL
THE NARRATIVES.
FIRST IT WAS IN THE ARTS.
THEN IT WAS THE COLLEGES.
THEN IT WAS THE MEDIA AND NOW
IT'S THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
IT'S A MASS MEDIA CARJACKING.
AND NOW ELON MUSK IS POINTING IT
OUT.
WE REJECT THE DIVERSITY OF
IDEAS, YOU END UP WITH
CENSORSHIP AND SHADOW PANNING.
IT'S WHY NEARLY ALL WHO WERE
LEFT BACK ON TWITTER WERE FROM
THE RIGHT AND NOT THE LEFT.
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE
RUNNING TWITTER, THERE WAS
NOTHING FROM THE LEFT THAT
ACTUALLY POSED A THREAT.
WELL, TELL THAT TO EPSTEIN.
[LAUGHS]
THAT'S WHY MUSK ISN'T ARGUING
FOR NEW POLICY.
HE UNDERSTANDS FREEDOM OF
SPEECH.
IT'S ONLY PERVERTED WHEN YOU
KEEP THOSE WHO DISAGREE WITH
YOUR IDEAS OUT OF THE
DISCUSSION.
IT'S LIKE SAYING I AM ALL FOR
DESEGREGATION AS LONG AS YOU
KEEP THOSE BROWN PEOPLE OFF MY
PROPERTY.
ENOUGH ABOUT MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT GUESTS.
WHO NEEDS A FERRARI WHEN YOU'VE
GOT A FORD THIS HOT.
COHOST OF "THE FIVE," HAROLD
FORD JR..
SHE'S THE BEST THING TO COME OUT
OF THE NAVY SINCE POPEYE.
FORMER STATE DEPARTMENT
SPOKESWOMAN AND FOUNDER OF
POLARIS, NATIONAL SECURITY
MORGAN ORTAGUS.
HE SOUNDS LIKE A COMEDIAN BUT
LOOKS LIKE A PISTACHIO.
COMEDIAN AND COHOST OF "THE GYM
NORTON AND SAM ROBERTS SHOW" ON
SIRIUS XM, JIM NORTON.
SHE TOLD RUDOLPH TO GET A NOSE
JOB.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
JIM, ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO SEE
YOU, YOU LOOK GREAT.
APPARENTLY YOU'VE BEEN KEEPING
IN SHAPE.
>> Jim: I HAVE PRAYED YOU'RE
GOING TO GET A LOT OF LETTERS
FROM PISTACHIOS AND GREASE AT
YOUR COMPARISON.
>> Greg: YOU UNDERSTAND
CENSORSHIP.
YOU'VE BEEN SHADOW BANDON GRINR
MANY TIMES.
IT'S NOT EVEN ABOUT SPEECH.
YOU SEE WHAT MUSK IS DOING, KIND
OF SHINING A LIGHT.
>> Jim: THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
SHOT THEY WERE -- THOUGHT THEY
WERE SHADOW BANNED.
EVERYBODY WAS JUST IGNORING THEM
WITH THE REASON THAT PRESS IS
REALLY TOUCHING THIS, CNN, THEY
WERE COMPLICIT.
IF THEY DO, THEN THEY HAVE TO
DISCUSS WHY THEY DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT THE LAPTOP STORY TO BEGIN
WITH.
THEY DON'T CRITICIZE TWITTER FOR
THIS FOR THE SAME REASON I DON'T
CRITICIZE PEOPLE WHO CHEAT IN
RELATIONSHIPS.
I GET IT AND I DO IT AND I WANT
TO CONTINUE DOING IT SO I'M NOT
GOING TO CRITICIZE IT.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
OH.
HAROLD, HOW ARE YOU?
>> Harold: I'M GOOD.
GOOD TO BE BACK WITH YOU.
>> Greg: IS ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO SEE YOU.
HOPE YOU HAD A GREAT WEEKEND AND
A GREAT NEXT WEEKEND.
>> Harold: I SPENT THE LAST
TWO HOURS WITH YOU.
>> Greg: I COULD STARE AT YOU
FOREVER.
BECAUSE YOUR BRAIN IS FILLED
WITH THOUGHTS.
ISN'T THIS MAINLY ABOUT THE FACT
THAT WHEN IT COMPANY IS FILLED
WITH THE SAME BELIEF SYSTEMS,
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET.
YOU PERCEIVE CERTAIN THREATS
DIFFERENT THAN I PERCEIVE
THREATS.
IT >> Harold: IT'S A PRIVATE
COMPANY, THEY CAN DO WHAT THEY
WANT AND WE CAN VOTE WITH WHAT
WE WANT TO DO.
THE THING THAT TROUBLES ME MOST
ABOUT THE STORY IS WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WAS COLLABORATION WITH
THE GOVERNMENT AROUND WHO TO
CENTER AND WHO NOT TO CENSOR AND
HOPEFULLY WE LEARNED ABOUT THAT
AND IF TAKES AN INVESTIGATION BY
ONE OF THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES
IN THE CONGRESS OR EVEN FOR THEM
TO RELEASE MORE INFORMATION,
THAT'S WHAT I AM MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT.
I SHARE THE VIEW THAT
CONGRESSMAN RO KHANNA SHARES.
I DON'T AGREE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, I DIDN'T AGREE
WITH MANY OF HIS VIEWS BUT WHEN
THE GOVERNMENT COLLABORATES WITH
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PRESS
ORGANIZATION, THAT'S ALARMING TO
ME.
WITH A PRIVATE COMPANY WANTS TO
TAKE DOWN CERTAIN LANGUAGE,
DOESN'T WANT CERTAIN VIEWS TO BE
SHOWN, WE CAN QUARREL WITH THEM
IN THE MARKET PLACE WITH THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT BE PART OF
THAT DECISION.
>> Greg: WELL SAID, HAROLD.
MORGAN, I WAS NOT AWARE THAT
NEVERLAND HAD AN NFL FOOTBALL
TEAM.
>> Morgan: I AM THE CAPTAIN.
>> Greg: FANTASTIC.
IT'S AN AMAZING LOOK.
WHERE IS THIS FROM?
WHAT ARE YOU WEARING IS WHAT I
AM ASKING?
>> Morgan: THE SYSTEM OF PLACE
IN NASHVILLE.
THEY ARE BIG FANS OF YOU.
>> Greg: EXCELLENT.
WELL, THAT'S A SHAME.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
IF YOU THINK WE'LL EVER BE ABLE
TO KIND OF STOP THIS, THIS
SLOWLY OVERTAKING PLATFORMS AND
EVERYTHING BY YOUNG LIBERAL
KIDS?
IS IN THAT KIND OF LIKE THE
INEVITABILITY?
WE JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO EDUCATE THEM?
>> Morgan: MAYBE.
I WAS MOST DISAPPOINTED IN THIS
STORY FIND OUT IS A MEMBER OF
THE GOVERNMENT YOU KO
COLLABORATE ON TWITTER.
I WAS IN GOVERNMENT.
I WISH I WOULD'VE KNOWN THIS.
I WOULD'VE BLOCKED ALL OF MY
EX-BOYFRIENDS AND PEOPLE THAT I
DON'T LIKE.
MISSED OPPORTUNITY.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING TO ME
BECAUSE IT WOULD SEEM SO
SURPRISED BY THIS STORY BUT I'M
LIKE NO, OF COURSE THEY WERE
DOING THIS.
THEY LET THE AYATOLLAH ON.
WE SEE THIS EVERY DAY MEDIA, HOW
WE ARE TREATED SO BE MORE
SHOCKING TO ME IF THE TWITTER
FILE SHOWED THEY WEREN'T DOING
THIS, THAT THEY WEREN'T SHADOW
PANNING PEOPLE.
>> Greg: WHERE YOU GOING NEXT?
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ON ACTIVE
DUTY.
WHERE DO YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO GO?
YOU'RE STILL IN THE NAVY.
>> Morgan: I'M GOING TO GO
KILL BAD GUYS.
>> Greg: I HOPE THOSE SHOULDER
PADS ARE BULLETPROOF.
>> Morgan: I WILL LOOK A
LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
KAT, WERE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS
INFORMATION?
PLEASE ELABORATE ON YOUR
OPINION.
>> Kat: NO, I WAS NOT.
FOR EXAMPLE.
I FEEL STUPID EVEN USING THE
WORD FOUND OUT.
MAYBE SOME PEOPLE FOUND OUT THAT
I DIDN'T FIND IT OUT.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY DIDN'T LOOK AT
THE POLICY AND DECIDE TO BAN
TRUMP BASED ON THAT, THEY
DECIDED TO BAN DROP AND TRY TO
FIGURE WHAT POLICY THEY COULD
USE TO JUSTIFY IT BUT YOU CAN'T
BE SHOCKED.
IF YOU SAY YOUR SHOCKED AND
YOU'RE SAYING THAT WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY THOUGHT WAS THE IF
TRUMP STATE ON TWITTER IT WAS
DANGEROUS AND PEOPLE WOULD DIE.
NOBODY BELIEVE THAT.
IN --
THE FACT THAT THEY SAID THEY DID
IS WHAT'S RIDICULOUS SO I HAVE A
HARD TIME BEING SHOCKED.
WHAT IS SHOCKING IS THAT IT TOOK
THIS LONG FOR PEOPLE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
THAT'S IT.
>> Jim: THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY
WAS INTERESTING.
PARTS WERE NEWS AND PARTS THAT
WEREN'T.
ANYTHING TO DO WITH UKRAINE OR
CHINA WAS FAIR GAME.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO LEAVE THE
PICTURES OUT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
RELEVANT.
I WAS GOING TO SAY.
>> Greg: WE NEVER BROUGHT IT
UP.
>> Jim: NOT ME AND YOU PAID
PRIVATELY, WE HAVE.
NOT ME AND YOU.
IF I HAD A PENIS LIKE HUNTER.
>> Greg: THERE WAS A BAIT AND
SWITCH.
YOU WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
SERIOUS STUFF ON THE LAPTOP AND
THE MEDIA WOULD GO OH, YOU JUST
WANT TO EMBARRASS HUNTER BIDEN
FOR PICTURES.
I DON'T CARE.
I'M SAYING THAT THERE'S OTHER
STUFF GOING ON WITH UKRAINE AND
CHINA.
>> Jim: THE OTHER STUFF.
THE CRACK SMOKING STUFF, HE'S A
FUN DUDE.
>> Kat: I AGREE.
WHO CARES.
>> Greg: DON'T DO CRACK.
>> Kat: I NEVER WOULD.